today's design by drew we're going to
work with a viewer who had a design
dilemma in her bathroom
and all of the items we chose are under
40
take a look hi i'm cara from boston
and i desperately need a bathroom
upgrade every girl
at least me i want a place where i can
go after a long day and just take a bath
relax decompress do a facial just
practice some self-care
in this plane depressing cluttered
bathroom
isn't it i need baskets i need to
declutter
this isn't a place where i go to relax
this bathroom gives me anxiety
so i need your help please help me put a
vibe to this place a goodbye
well i was excited about this come on
down
cara you're the next contestant designed
by drew
hi hi cara
nice to meet you drew i'm really excited
to meet you in person
um we put a lot of fun and tlc
into your bathroom which you deserve to
have it be the space that you desire it
to be
yep i agree all right we've got some
budget friendly secrets
um that will make your bathroom dreams
hopefully come true and it's game show
week so we're going to do things a
little differently
and we're going to reveal the prices all
right first
you had an attacher over your toilet
which is very smart and sensible because
it basically adds
a shelving unit but it can take up
either side with the legs so instead
bye bye we have floating shelves that
way
you have more room on either side of the
toilet so how much do you think these
are
i'm gonna say uh 25.99
33. these
are from pottery barn and i just fell in
love with them because
i like the brass detail and the white
shelf all right
now we got you some canisters um that i
really love there's white with a nice
light wood top how much do you think
these are
i'm going to say those are 15
they're under 20. so ver you're good at
this cara
okay these are each from the container
store and i really love
the design of them i like a little wood
element
a little metal a little wood now
add a little faux greenery to give the
room
a little life so how much do you think
the faux greenery
is 10 bucks
[Applause]
what a bargain and they're from target
okay let's talk about your vanity area
we put coordinated marble bath
accessories
the reason i went with these is because
i wanted neutral white
i want these to literally if you're not
looking almost go away
i want like phantom utility holders here
how much do you think that these are 15
they're each under 30. wow cara
okay and these are from cb2 which is
really one of my favorite companies boy
are they chic all right now i wanted to
bring in
a beautiful toilet paper holder because
i noticed that yours was in a little
like storage thing at the foot of your
toilet
so i got rid of that and i got you this
um
beautiful toilet paper holder that's
really pretty
now um what do you think that is let me
guess you think it's two dollars don't
you car
no it's 20. uh okay let's see
it's 39 cara this is from pottery barn
and what i did was i got you a towel
hook
to match because it drives me a little
crazy when
the hardware doesn't match so this is
just a beautiful piece of hardware and
it actually has two ways of holding
something
but i wanted to bring in a little color
of this beautiful towel to kind of go
with the greenery
so how much do you think this is let me
guess 50 cents
um i'm going back and shopping um i
think
it's ten dollars for the hook i'm sure
it's more
twenty three dollars
um okay and that's from pottery barn too
i really loved this turkish towel
because it's really soft and it's not
too bulky
and it's going to drape it also feels
really good on the body
one of my other favorite things about
these is they're great for hair because
they don't do that like
i'm carrying an rv on my head you know
they like they're nice and tight to the
head
you see what i'm saying so
how much do you think the towel is
thirty dollars
oh cara it's eleven dollars finally
yes finn fantastic
okay i love it lastly i did a bath mat
now you have to be really careful when
you're choosing a bath mat
also in this case size does matter
especially for the room
so i went with a tone that matches your
floor
and i got this hold on let's see
how much do you think this is cara
um i'm going to say the bath mat is 15
no cara it's 39 it's twice
what you thought it was and that's uh
from
cb2 okay cara here's your new bathroom
this is all coming home with you for
free like this is your new bathroom
thank you so much okay so what do you
think cara
i'm obsessed i feel like you know me
this is this is the vibe i've been
wanting
really um i think yes i'm all about it
clean white i love the greenery i love
the wood i love
i love all of the um all the different
fixtures and the mixed metals i think it
looks phenomenal
excited also i just want to send you a
500
gift card in case there's any little
odds and ends that you want to get
thank you so much
thank you cara so much and you know
feel free to send me a picture
of you rocking your towel love it
um also when you walk around with them
you feel like you're on holiday thank
you cara i really appreciate
getting to do this with you
[Music]